[Music]
the golden knights ross were continuing
to change from the misfits
fans fell in love with ryan reeves is
now the latest player to get traded most
of us
are still coming to terms with losing
marc-andre fleury and now this
john treach breaking down this latest
move john that's right the salary cap is
a friend of league parody
and an enemy of local popular players
being marketable and in demand comes
with a price in pro sports
in the last year the golden knights have
shipped away fan favorites in bulk
nate schmidt marc-andre fleury and now
ryan reeves
the golden misfits enforcer was traded
to the new york rangers in exchange for
a third round draft pick
the move is to shed salary reeves was
acquired in a trade with pittsburgh in
the stanley cup final run of 2018.
he had a distinct role with the golden
knights fourth line as an energy guy
and a tough cut as well as a likeable
guy perhaps las vegas last gift to ryan
was the rain today he can focus on the
move to new york and not need to
threaten your neighbors to turn off
their sprinklers he was an advocate of
water conservation the city will miss
his enthusiasm and ability to heckle the
san jose sharks